gentlemen i always like to think of the
batman movies as like the most sort of
versatile
type of superhero movies and the
expectations are always pretty high for
what's going to happen next in each one
are those expectations for you guys like
a motivator or are you not even paying
attention to that when you're going into
the project
i think a little bit of both
uh you know you're aware you can't not
be aware of the passion that
fans have for
these characters and these stories and
it's wonderful
um
[Music]
but if you're aware of that while you're
working on
any given scene i don't think you're
going to be able to make the film that's
going to satisfy that passion you kind
of got to focus on
what you're doing and
what we were doing was trying to realize
matt reeve's script which is you know
brilliant and a story for the times a
batman film so we're trying to do
justice to that and if we do justice to
that
which does justice i think and pays
homage to the history of the franchise
then we'll satisfy the passions of those
fans but it's just too much to kind of
be conscious of while you're working
it's just it's a lot it's incredible
yeah paul this is a riddler like we've
never i think never even imagined before
let alone never seen before but there
are some cool little nods to things in
the past like i could be mistaken but i
thought i heard a little frank gorshin
giggle in one scene there for those for
those little details is that something
that you come up with is that something
you guys talk about beforehand is that
planned or just off the cuff well there
there there certainly are details i mean
i i was
as surprised as probably you were when i
first read matt's script and the
iteration of this character that he came
up with in the point of view that he
brought to it i thought it was sort of
ingenious to use the the cards and the
to the batman and the question mark in
this way and i do think that
matt
is a very very very very thorough
filmmaker so he has got stuff in there
that we probably don't even know about
and i think we are all actors who are
trying to bring everything to it as well
and try to be as thorough and as
passionate as these fans are so there is
stuff in there but uh
i can't remember at the end of the day
he's just trying to i mean each day
you're just trying to give give what you
got and so
i don't remember if any
laugh was conscious or unconscious or
what
very cool now i know
a lot of these movies are totally really
different but we're in an era where
you can kind of see this
different characters from different
types of batman movie and dc movie
coming together like this multiversal
thing is there
a world where you can see
like you know for example your riddler
going up against michael keaton's batman
oh golly i i i don't i don't know i will
say as a kid that tim burton michael
keaton batman oh man i loved that movie
uh
um but uh i'm not sure this i think our
film one thing i like about it is its
contact with reality
uh and and i think that's what makes it
sort of thrilling and scary and
so i guess i i cannot imagine that the
gotham
that is presented to you in the film is
a is a
is a multiverse
but uh yeah
well gentlemen it's a phenomenal piece
of work i cannot wait to watch it again
uh thank you so much for this time all
the best
you